today I'm gonna talk a little bit about
mobile phone data and what kind of data
of mobile phone operators recorded and
also while recording it it's not
sinister it's actually got some really
good reasons and it's got a couple of
really good things that you might not
necessarily think of at first glance
we probably start with what mobile phone
that actually is and how it's been
collected and what is actually being
collected so the most important thing is
with any kind of event so we call these
Network events is we record a time so
this is a day month year and the time of
day and then they record an ID for the
handset that is coming from so this will
be your mobile phone
so this ID is not in plain text so no
one actually knows that's you but rather
the ID is being hashed so it's just an
anonymized ID essentially and it also
records an identifier for the cell phone
so the cell tower dish that actually
serviced your call or USMS or other
event so general it's the time it's the
identifier for your handset and the
location now there's a number of other
things being collected but they're
mainly of interest to the operator
itself citizens something like how much
did this phone call cost for example
what account a charger to use is that
something that was included in your
contract is that something that was not
included in your contract and has to be
taken off your balance in the case of
pace you go or is that something that
has to be stuck on at the end and then
you see an extra charge on your bill
there's also things like what country
code did you call from is that we use
someone from overseas who's visiting
here so we know ok they need to charge
this back to your network operator the
other country and that's basically the
most important thing so being connected
so they never collect any information of
what is actually inside your event so
let's say you send an SMS they might
know how many characters you SMS were
but then never know what the content of
the SMS itself was generally network
operators differentiate between what's
called active events and passive events
now active events are things that you
actually do so this is you send an SMS
you make a phone call or receive a phone
call you browse the Internet you
move from what's called a location area
to another one now with a location area
you've got multiple cell towers in
various places and then some of these
cell towers a group together into what's
called a location area and if you move
from one location area to another so
let's say you go from here
all the way over here they would know
when you cross this boundary here and it
would basically make a notice off you
cross that boundary then they also
record it if you switch between 2g 3G
and 4G and in terms of passive events
there is a ping that's being sent out
every couple hours so let's say your
phone is being stationary somewhere
you're not using it you're not doing
anything for three hours
it would then ping and basically say oh
that person is still active that phone
is still thing and that's the general
events that are being recorded now the
time between them varies so if you think
about how many times you're sending in a
SMS how many times you're making a phone
call
compared to what you did 10 years ago
that's probably a lower number right now
whereas if you think about how much
you're using the mobile internet now
compared to about three or four years
ago that number is probably much much
higher and that number is also increased
with the amount of smart phones that
we've got in general circulation what
makes this a computer science question
so one of the things we're talking about
it is because there's a huge amount of
data it's being generated and there's
quite a huge interest in data science
right now and in computer science
community and also in the wider
community and it also has a lot of
application areas beyond traditional
computer science and analyzing what's
happening in the network to fields like
epidemiology to fields like urban
planning transport planning to finance
and a lot of other fields where that
data can generate huge insights so
epidemiology is this study of the spread
of diseases so one thing people might be
interested in is trying to predict where
diseases are going to spread next so
this was used quite extensively in
Africa when we had the recent Ebola
crisis all the way to the recent Zika
virus and various other diseases where
network operators have been working with
local authorities and Internet
organizations to try and identify areas
that are going to be prone to spread of
diseases also identify communities that
may be at risk of contracting diseases
or infected communities and trying to
identify where that disease might spread
next we've seen large organizations be
happy worried that all the states are
about is being collected no we should
not be worried so a lot of organizations
and by organizations I mean mobile phone
operators when they collected data it's
being anonymized before it actually
reaches their systems to some extent and
what they internally work with us also
already anonymized so no one actually
gets to see the raw data itself so
personally I've done a lot of work
around tracking activity based land-use
and tracking transport demand so
transport demand is you're trying to
figure out how many people are going
from A to B how many people are going
from B to a how many people are going
from C to D etc so this gives you a
really quick overview of wider transport
patterns in a city so this is let's say
you want to see how many people are
going from London to Manchester how many
people for Manchester to London etc so
you can try and figure out where you
want to maybe build an x-ray line or
where you maybe want to build a new
motorway whereas the activity-based
land-use is looking at a city itself and
it's focusing on identifying where
people work where we've got residential
areas where we've got commercial areas
and how all these different things fit
together and how cities involved over
time information insight collaboration
or network operator to make this
available or do you need to work with
lots and lots of different providers no
that is a tricky one and you kind of hit
the nail on the head so one of the
problems is and this is something that's
not just in Herrin
to analyzing mobile phone data but also
part of any observation or study you do
you get some kind of bias because you
always only get a snapshot of what is
actually happening
so we are trying to accommodate for the
fact that then one network operator
doesn't generally cover the entire
network and represent the entire
population by using what's called an
expansion factor so you try and figure
out different ways to come up an
expansion factor so one way is for
example in the UK you might look at a
particular area you where you identify
let's say 100 people as having their
most frequently visited location during
the night there which is their home and
then you say okay we look at the census
population and we look at the hosts that
we identify we divide it and that gives
us the scale factor and we use that
scale factor or expansion factor
throughout to adjust all of the journeys
they're doing and that gives us a like a
slight approximation of what you would
see in a national Travel Survey and
there's various other methods but that's
one of the most commonly used ones
particularly an area where you actually
got census information available when
you talk about something in kind of
those generic terms of their most
occupied nighttime location is that
feels like that would be a way to
identify someone from their phone just
because you could see where they lived
yeah sort of so the thing to bear in
mind there is if you let's say you look
at a cell tower and you have the
coverage area of that cell tower so
traditionally with GPS you could say
okay a person is here person is here
person is here person is here see you
know their home location is probably
somewhere inside that circle but with a
cell tower you just know that connected
to a tower which can have a radius of a
couple hundred meters it can be
particularly a view in rural areas so if
you're outside large cities there can be
a couple of kilometers apart and you
just know their home location is
somewhere inside that a couple hundred
meter radius or because the cell towers
are next to each other and their
coverage areas overlap it's like you can
be anywhere along this circle here now
you could potentially be in the middle
generally the middle also tends to be a
couple hundred meters apart and it
becomes really difficult and especially
as we move more to
was living in high-rise houses it
becomes really difficult to discern
where people actually are so sometimes
he fought please wood dies he often
would make backup copies let's try this
one sounds more hopeful and so there was
this game called Lander which became the
full games arch and when this game was
released it was sort of full 3d graphics